It's been a long time since Mike Myers took
us on a groovy journey through time and espionage
with his Austin Powers franchise, a three-film
romp that featured a star-studded cast of
past and future celebrities.
In the decades since, some of these actors
have hung onto their mojo, while others are
resting on their laurels.
Here's a look back at where the cast was before
the films, and where they are now.
Mike Myers
Before he played Austin Powers, Dr. Evil,
and the endlessly hungry Fat Bastard, Mike
Myers played a slew of characters during his
six-year run on Saturday Night Live — including
metalhead Wayne Campbell, who of course appeared
in his own feature film franchise.
Once the Austin Powers trilogy ended, Myers
went on to voice the beloved title character
in the Shrek franchise.
But sadly, his other work wasn't as well-received;
2008's The Love Guru won a terrible trifecta
of Razzie Awards for Worst Actor, Worst Screenplay,
and Worst Picture—plus a nomination for
Myers for Worst Actor of the Decade.
"Ouch baby, very ouch."
Still, Myers has left his mark on Hollywood:
his Walk of Fame star was unveiled in 2002,
and in his home country of Canada, he's a
national hero with his own commemorative stamp.
And if you're more likely to see him at a
Toronto Maple Leafs game than on the big screen
these days, it might be because the Austin
Powers and Shrek franchises combined made
him even wealthier than Dr. Evil.
Elizabeth Hurley
This English actress is probably best known
for her role as Vanessa Kensington in the
first two Austin Powers films, but those are
just a pair of entries in a lengthy filmography
that includes movies like Rowing with the
Wind and Bedazzled, where she plays a smoking
hot devil.
And offscreen, Hurley is famous in her own
right for her modeling work — and by association
for her 13-year relationship with Hugh Grant,
standing by him during the 1995 scandal in
which Grant after being caught with a Hollywood
prostitute.
"I did a bad thing, and there you have it."
These days, Hurley is flying solo and staying
busy — running a beachwear company and playing
Queen Helena on the E! television series The
Royals.
Michael York
Long before Austin Powers hit theaters, the
English actor who plays Basil Exposition was
a veteran of stage and screen since the mid-1960s,
starring in films like The Taming of the Shrew
and Romeo and Juliet, and on Broadway in the
original production of Tennessee Williams'
Out Cry.
And don't even get us started on his television
credits.
York reprised his role for all three Austin
Powers films, but since 2010, the actor has
rarely been seen onscreen — and has been
undergoing treatment for amyloidosis, a rare
medical condition caused by the abnormal production
of insoluble proteins in the body.
Mimi Rogers
Austin Powers: International Man of Mystery
is merely a side note on the resume of this
actress, producer and competitive poker player,
who famously starred in the 1991 religious
drama The Rapture.
After the first Austin Powers movie, Rogers
went on to appear in films like Lost in Space
and Ginger Snaps, and on popular television
shows including The X-Files and Mad Men.
Robert Wagner
Long before he starred as Dr. Evil's right-hand
man, Robert Wagner was one of the hardest
working actors in Hollywood.
"Who does number two work for?"
Who does number two work for?
Pretty much everyone!
Wagner's starring roles include TV shows like
It Takes a Thief, Switch, and Hart to Hart
— and in the twenty-first century, you could
find him on Two and a Half Men and NCIS.
But Wagner might be most famous for his role
in one of classic Hollywood's biggest tragedies.
In 1981, Wagner's Oscar-nominated wife Natalie
Wood drowned while sailing off the coast of
California with Wagner and actor Christopher
Walken.
Wood's death was ruled an accident, but lingering
questions about the possibility of foul play
resulted in the investigation being re-opened
in 2013, with the Los Angeles coroner's office
amending the actress' cause of death to include
"undetermined factors".
The decision to reopen the investigation was
supported by Wagner, who's still mourning
his wife's death more than thirty years later.
"I don't think you ever overcome it - and
why should you?"
Seth Green
After he played Dr. Evil's son Scott in all
three Austin Powers movies, Hollywood was
only too happy to throw a frickin' bone to
Seth Green.
Twenty years after he refused to hug his evil
dad onscreen, Green has found massive success
as the creator (and producer, writer, director,
and main vocal talent) of Adult Swim's stop-motion
sketch comedy show Robot Chicken.
Green was also a staple of comedies like Can't
Hardly Wait and Without a Paddle, and he's
been heard but not seen as the voice of Family
Guy's Chris Griffin.
"Stop it!"
"Ahhh!"
"My hat!"
"Haha.
Wear it NOW!"
And with various prestigious awards under
his belt for his work on Robot Chicken, this
is one Austin Powers star who hasn't lost
his mojo since 1997.
Mindy Sterling
Although Sterling got her start playing with
puppets on the children's TV series Dusty's
Treehouse, it's her role as Dr. Evil's associate
Frau Farbissina where she truly made her mark
on Hollywood's hearts… and eardrums.
"SCOTT!"
So you probably won't recognize Sterling from
anywhere else—unless you watch TV with your
kids.
Despite her street cred as Evil's girl Friday,
the actress is a popular casting pick on Disney,
Nickelodeon, and other children's networks,
where her comedy credentials definitely make
her well-suited for family-friendly roles.
Will Ferrell
After notching his big-screen breakthrough
in Austin Powers: The Spy Who Shagged Me,
Mike Myers' fellow SNL veteran became a comedy
star in his own right, bringing laughs in
films like Old School, Anchorman, and Talladega
Nights.
"Here's the deal, I'm the best there is, plain
and simple…
I mean, I wake up in the morning and I p-ss
excellence."
Ferrell also had one of the most memorable
runs in Saturday Night Live history, where
he became famous for impersonating famous
figures like George W. Bush, Cubs announcer
Harry Caray, and Jeopardy! host Alex Trebek.
Nowadays, he's still making movies — and
making fun of himself, often to earn money
for charitable causes, as with his "10 Major
League Baseball Teams in One Day" stunt from
2015.
Heather Graham
Way before she played Felicity Shagwell in
the Austin Powers sequel, Heather Graham broke
out in Hollywood in the late 1980s with License
to Drive, followed by Twin Peaks and Boogie
Nights.
And after traveling back to 1969 for The Spy
Who Shagged Me, Graham didn't slow down
After playing Felicity Shagwell, Graham went
on to star in films like Committed, Say It
Isn't So, and the Hangover series, and more
recently, she's been featured in recurring
roles on series like Showtime's Californication
and Netflix's Flaked.
"I'm pretty enough to be on TV, right?"
Beyoncé
Unless you've been living under a rock, this
is one Austin Powers alumna who needs no introduction.
The 22-time Grammy Award winner is one of
America's Top 50 Richest Self-Made Women,
with more than 100 million records sold worldwide
— and that's just her solo career.
But the majority of Beyoncé's success came
after she played the leading lady Foxxy Cleopatra
in Austin Powers in Goldmember, even if she
was already well on her way to superstardom
by then as the lead singer of Destiny's Child.
Michael Caine
This icon of the British screen has been acting
since the 1950s, and he was an Oscar nominee
long before he played Austin Powers' father
in Goldmember.
Caine worked steadily throughout the 1970s
and 80s, starring in films like Get Carter
and Woody Allen's Hannah and Her Sisters,
for which he earned the first of two Academy
Awards for Best Supporting Actor.
But since he showed the world where Austin
got his groove, Caine is probably best known
for his work with director Christopher Nolan
— particularly in his role as Alfred Pennyworth
in the Dark Knight trilogy, where, as Nolan's
favorite cast member, he had all the best
lines.
"Some men just want to watch the world burn."
Verne Troyer
Though he's best known for playing the miniature
clone of Dr. Evil, Verne Troyer has a big
presence in Hollywood.
The 2 feet 8 inch tall actor has brought his
unique stature to films like Pinocchio's Revenge
and Mighty Joe Young — and he was the first
to play Griphook the goblin in Harry Potter
and the Sorcerer's Stone, though he was replaced
in later films by fellow actor and friend
Warwick Davis.
Troyer also maintains an active social media
presence, where he's recently admitted to
battling alcohol addiction and thanked his
fans for their support.
Fred Savage
"So you're the…
MO…
MO...
Apart from this bit as a spy with a prominent mole in Goldmember, there's one role that
will follow Fred Savage for the rest of his
life.
Of course, we're talking about The Wonder
Years, where the young actor earned two Golden
Globe nominations and two Emmy nominations
for playing the lead role of Kevin Arnold
— although yes, that's also him in The Princess
Bride, giving the stink-eye to all things
romantic:
"Is this a kissing book?"
After his role in the Austin Powers franchise,
Savage moved on mostly to voice acting, with
appearances on Family Guy, Kim Possible, and
BoJack Horseman, and he's kept busy behind
the camera as a TV director.
But if you're dying to see his face onscreen
— without that mole in the way — he's
also getting back into acting, with starring
roles in both seasons of The Grinder and the
Netflix series Friends from College.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!